I want to show you this clip this is
Bill Maher on Jimmy Kimmel who is not a
sane Democrat in September of 2021
talking about how the Democrats and the
mainstream media basically
cause their base not to believe in truth
in this case he's talking about covid
but I think you can see how that then
gets extrapolated through the race thing
the gender thing and the rest of it take
a look
but I have to cite a survey that was in
the New York Times which is a liberal
paper so they weren't looking for this
answer but they were talking about uh
this the question was what do you think
the chances are that you would have to
go to the hospital if you got coveted
and Democrats thought that was way
higher than Republicans 41 percent of
democrat and the answer is between one
and five percent okay
41 percent of Democrats thought it was
over 50 percent
another 28 thought it was 20 to 49 so 70
percent of Democrats thought it was way
way higher than it really was
liberal media has to take a little
responsibility for that
for scaring the out of people and
the reason why I'm bringing this up is
because it's much harder for every
touring act to sell tickets in blue
States oh interesting they're afraid to
go out of the house I see whereas in red
States it's all good to go uh-huh
so I just want to say to those people in
San Rafael in Pittsburgh and New York I
ain't going to give it to you I promise
I you know it's safe we we're doing
everything we can there's distancing
there's masking uh and enjoy live life
you did get it Embrace Life you did get
it
I got it after I was vaccinated
so you got to give Bill more credit
there right like he's going into a far
Lefty talk show host show now they're
friends actually we discussed it when I
was on the club random podcast their
friends obviously you know my feelings
about blackface Jimmy Kimmel but the
audience there you could feel how quiet
they are and how afraid of laughing
there because he's calling out their
machine it is the Democrat machine that
made Democrats go covid crazy it is the
Democrat and media machine right it is
the cable news networks it's big Tech
all that that monstrous machine we're
always talking about that has caused a
certain set of people that used to be
sane moderates to all go bananas so they
can't differentiate between boys and
girls anymore they can't accept that we
are not a systemically racist Nation etc
etc so good for Bill Maher for trying to
call that out
[Music]
foreign